a new game just started and my opponent
has got only one guitar better than no
guitar I guess okay I'm a symmetrical
English and here's the big parting of
the waves the waves not not the waves of
the ways black can play multiple lines
I'm playing this weird-looking setup
which has been pinned from sort of
invented by bent Larson their dear soon
to take him this is quite interesting
the idea on he has played there multiple
times with both colors and it leads to a
strange kind of position where black
exactly with black playing a 5 later and
it's it's very a similar to an Enzo
Indian the only weird aspect as this g6
f5 stuff so b6 now but the long diagonal
is somewhat creepy it looks quite
dangerous maybe I need to play work v8
first now let's let's start with Ruby
aid ok somewhat slower move I wonder
about 90 form attacking c3 but probably
in the long run this this is so this is
bad ok continuous with the plan what I
don't like in general about this
position of course is my king I don't
really know where to where to put the
king
of course you can cancel short but
you've got this g 6 f five moves plate
and this is can easily lead to end one
of those kind of positions where you
want to play f5 back to f7 okay so he is
intending you for I think quite down
quite logical only for I can take addy
for though hmm yeah Bishop a six or is
this far too ambitious it's really a
problem that I have half a plan that I
felt on the need to play rugby eight as
some not to being able to castle as a
problem and I'm sure basics I don't know
yeah well I got tempted by this this
idea laudanum always was a player that I
really liked mostly because he played
lots of concepts that really am you
needed some time to to to understand
what what he what is doing at all simply
a very M original and inventive plan
yeah yeah I understand he wants a GUI
form okay I cannot I cannot leave the
cape on the eight all the time only for
I want to take on deform not that I'm
particularly sure that this is good yeah
taking on before right it's a porn but
all this
looks dangerous a very rare case also
when I'm ahead on the clock this really
doesn't happen often in numb those blitz
games with with live live comments hmm
hmm I take with the Queen that's just
hanging on c6 right there is no trick
probably not i can take c 3 maybe this
mean maybe maybe I should take c3 don't
see why not at the moment 94 or 95 even
who I have an idea I want to play book
look at five from Kate eggs with the
Queen anyway but Queen f5 now I'm
threatening made on F to wear or almost
made okay can exchange it takes 26 okay
this is nonsense so 95 yeah come on try
95
oops i have Bishop e7 in the position
exchanging this bishops yeah sometimes
get remarks on the videos that with with
this not with this huge time span that I
often have that I must be a terrible
time travel um addict in in in over the
broad classical games in fact this isn't
the case at all I'm i rarely get into
time travel um it's often just the other
way around i'm playing rather quickly
and in tournament chess I wiki five I
completely overlook this shouldn't
couldn't chat so much rookie Pfeifer
just was just over ah and somehow I
thought I wasn't so so bad in this
position wait if I take a 527 is there
may be some possibility he's very weak
on the light squares and of course my
king is also a catastrophe but this is
the only the only kind of chance that
I've got rooked the eight and then queen
moves and Bishop before attacking the
rook and threatening Mukti one mate if
this would work it would be just one
hundred percent pure luck but I Scott
Queenie 626
but this he needs to do or Quincy 70
maybe anything if I thank you five is
just hanging ah ok let's maybe there's
some some trick left I mean I don't know
is that some trick yeah yeah at least I
only had one move them so this was easy
yeah Queen h5 is probably probably the
easiest way to do it he's got this
Bishop Bishop g2 yeah as long as this
rookie saying I'm not resigning ah the
one is covered so yeah I forgot about
that and so well let me just resign this
yeah i lost the gloucester threat here
somehow this is this
yeah maybe this was just a tad too
ambitious of course this is a rather
complicated position that's really not
not easy to assess i actually had
forgotten that c6 was hanging even after
the Queen trade the computer actually
wants a baby should be saved and gives
black a slight edge but well that's just
just complete completely am like a big
mass m and maybe they're even ways to
sacrifice the snide I mean this is the
strange see porn um it's worth something
yeah just just too complicated yeah I
hope you enjoyed it thanks for watching